Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten.
Weißt du was? Hasen graben gar keine Löcher.
Und Füchse sind gar keine Rudeltiere.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer 438 vom 7. September zwanzig zweiundzwanzig,
Und wir wissen Bescheid.
Wir haben's raus, ja, ja.
Das das wollen wir nochmal ganz klar sagen, dass wir einfach voll die Checker sind. Spätestens nachdem ihr uns äh in den Kommentaren die äh echte Geschichte erzählt habt, wissen wir Bescheid.
Bescheid jetzt. So ist es doch, oder.
Ja, wir wissen Bescheid. Wir wissen auch, äh wer den 9 Euro-Fond gemacht hat übrigens. Nämlich nicht ähm Arne Semsrott. Hat er nicht,
äh den 9 Euro beraten, genauso wie alle anderen, die da drauf stehen, um das zu unterstützen.
Und äh ja zu viel äh zu viel Lob für alle und ich würde sagen, das ist dann aus,
der Anfang von seinem die Kleinen, ja. Wenn er jetzt inzwischen, ja, das reicht jetzt, also der ja, nee, also sorry Arne. Ich meine, äh irgendwann ist auch mal Schluss
Also unterstützt dieses von Freiheitsfonds wer hat der gibt sanktionsfrei Sand im Getriebe peng und Wald statt Asphalt, das heißt haben sich jetzt sogar noch mehr Leute angeschlossen. Das kann jeder jeder kann das,
Ja? Da brauchst du überhaupt nicht von uns hier gelobt werden. Im Impressum stehen nämlich ganz andere Leute,
Äh die haben's gemacht. Das steht nämlich hier, verantwortlicher im Sinne der Datenschutz Gesetze, insbesondere EU-Datenschutzgrundverordnung ist,
Mario Burkart.
Nix kann der.
Ich würde sagen, Mario Burkert ist der neue Annems Rott.
Ja, bin einfach ersetzt.
Was ist da los?
Einfach mal den Twitter-Account übergeben und dann ist das auch offiziell.
Okay also der das ist der erste Fehler, den wir korrigieren müssen. Dann äh Tim ist.
Ich bin noch ein relativ neuer Staatsbürger, verstehst du? Ich bin mit den äh ganzen Dingen noch nicht so vertraut. Man muss sich da auch langsam erstmal reinarbeiten. Bisher hat mich das ja nicht so interessiert.
Man muss sich da erstmal ran deuten.
Ja man muss da so rein, kartoffelt werden, Randkartoffeln. Ich muss mich daran kartoffeln.
Ja wir haben über die Online-Ident-äh-Funktion äh gesprochen.
Und dann habe ich halt zu zu einem ich weiß, alles besser rant äh ausgeholt, so mit ja, man müsste aber,
Mal ganz anders machen und es gibt ja nur Personalausweis und was sollen denn die anderen machen und die haben ja alle gar keine Chance und so. Na ja, auf jeden Fall,
Von Tutten und Blasen keine Ahnung. Was gibt es alles schon, was ich gefordert habe?
Aber das äh zeigt endlich mal, dass du Brite bist. Man hat so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass das so ein britisches Ding ist, was alles und alle anderen denken so äh äh könnte.
Ja das ist äh was interessiert mich, was aufm Kontinent passiert. Ja ja.
Korrigiere dich. Korrigiere dich, Tim.
Also, es gibt tatsächlich eine sogenannte ID-Karte, das ist so eine Art Personalausweis für Leute, die nicht Deutsche sind. Warum
das nicht auch Personalausweis heißt, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht, weil ich hätte den Namen Personalausweis ganz gut, aber es läuft letzten Endes hier alles auch auf Personalausweisportal Punkt DE, ja?
Schönen Bundesministerium des Inneren und für, na, Linus, Heimat, Heimat, genau.
Heißt die wirklich noch so.
Ja, steht da noch.
Das hat die Nancy Phaser nicht weggemacht.
Weiß ich auch nicht. Ja, nicht, dass dann gleich wieder, dann kommen sie auch wieder alle an und so und die Nancy die die hat's nicht so mit der Heimat und so, ne? Na ja.
Geld sparen. Auf jeden Fall gibt's eine Karte für Bürgerinnen und Bürger der EU und des EWA. Also es geht sogar noch.
Über die äh Europäische Union äh hinaus.
Europäischer Wirtschaftsraum, ist ja dann äh mich äh innere, ist das irgendwie Norwegen und gehört die Schweiz auch dazu. Ich glaube, ja.
Auf jeden Fall ähm,
dürfte sich's dabei technisch äh letzten Endes um die selbe Technologie handeln und so was kann man beantragen. Da dachte ich mir so, aha,
Mal gucken irgendwie, das wäre ja mal interessant, so was zu beantragen, kann man nämlich auch als Deutscher, weil man ist ja dann EU-Bürger, also auch beantragen können,
Was meinst du, wie das geendet ist?
Es gibt keine Termine in Berlin für irgendwas. Also ich habe einfach geguckt, ja Termin, wann könnte ich hier beim Bürgerabend vorbeikommen und die nächsten drei Monate ist äh der Zeitraum, den du so überblicken kannst, dann gibt's einfach keine Termine. Nichts.
Aber aber du könntest es ja vielleicht online beantragen über all die Now oder so mit Videoident.
Superidee.
Ja, also das war jetzt nicht so erfolgreich. Außerdem gibt es auch noch den elektronischen Aufenthaltstitel der EAT.
Der äh ja auch so äh ähnlich aussieht,
auch so eine Art Personalausweis äh ist und der dann jetzt wiederum auch für Leute ist, die in irgendeiner Form
eben einen Aufenthaltstitel haben, also die in irgendeiner Form vorübergehend hier äh geduldet werden oder vielleicht auch dauerhaft, weiß ich nicht, ähm,
nicht technisch wirklich Bürger der EU oder des EWR sind,
Und auch damit soll im Prinzip theoretisch so eine Onlineidentifikation,
möglich sein, die Nutzung der Online-Ausweisfunktion ist freiwillig, wie es hier so schön heißt,
und ähm theoretisch wäre das so das Rüst äh Zeug mit mit denen so eine Online-Identifikation,
Gemacht werden könnte. Dann kam noch der Einwand, vielleicht noch eins, dann kam auch der Einwand so, dass ja diese Videoident Geschichte ein Jahr auch.
In die Lage versetzen würde, auch zu überprüfen, dass die Person, die das beantragt, auch wirklich auf dem Foto zu sehen ist.
Ja, kannst ja machen. Aber da musst du doch nicht den Ausweis drüber verifizieren. Dann machst du halt also,
dann machst du halt hier äh zeig mal dein Gesicht und äh halt mal äh deinen Ausweis da dran,
Aber also das Gesicht zu überprüfen ist, hätte ich den Ausweis zu überprüfen. Und.
Deswegen ist ja die EID-Funktion mit einer PIN geschützt,
damit sie genau dann nicht mehr funktioniert, wenn der Ausweis äh gestohlen wurde. Ja, also das Entscheidende an dieser äh dass es eine Smartcard ist, ist äh dass die Fälschung
des Ausweisdokumentes.
Nach also ökonomisch nicht möglich oder also sehr, sehr unwirtschaftlich ist auf diesem Wege, also die Prüfung des Zertifikates äh ist äh zu umgehen, äh wird enorm teuer.
Ähm,
und beziehungsweise wenn nicht sogar weitestgehend unmöglich für äh mit mit ja aufgrund der zu hohen Kosten äh im im Aufwand,
und damit hast du halt die Echtheit des Dokumentes geprüft.
Wie auch natürlich beim bei anderen Dingen hatten wir das ja auch schon, die Echtheit des Dokumentes heißt wiederum nicht, dass auch der richtige Mensch vor dir steht, insofern ist schon korrekt und deshalb müsste es dann natürlich auch das Foto vergleichen.
Genau deswegen ist er jetzt,
in der Regel eines drauf, ähm wobei, wenn man das jetzt zu Ende spinnt, bin ich auch ganz ehrlich, dann würde man natürlich sagen, ja okay, dafür haben wir ja inzwischen die zentrale biometrische Datenbank,
um zu gucken äh dass der Mensch, der sich da präsentiert, auch tatsächlich der Richtige ist.
Ja, also.
Aber das Ding in die Kamera zu halten, sorry.
Ja, also dieses ganze Wasserzeichen und dann Wackeln und so weiter, also das ist das ist einfach wirklich extrem
mühsam und man äh fragt sich halt, warum's nicht eigentlich ein Pusch
das dann auch mal wirklich zur Anwendung zu bringen, wenn andere Länder das auch schaffen. Aber ist dir das eigentlich schon jemals äh in deinem Leben vorgekommen, dass du diese Option angeboten bekommen hast und dass du die dann auch
genutzt hast.
Die E-ID-Funktion.
Ja des Persos zu nutzen.
Äh ich glaube bei Elster hätte ich das machen können, aber hat irgendwie nicht geklappt.
Und ansonsten habe ich mit der Ausweis-App mal ein bisschen rumgespielt. Äh da konnte ich mich dann habe ich mich erfolgreich selber identifiziert,
zuverlässig und ähm,
aber das ist ja genau der, das ist ja genau der der Punkt, den wir auch, den wir da immer wieder ansprechen in diesem Kontext diese also diese Technologie wurde da vor vielen Jahren eingebaut.
Und dann wurde nicht an ihrer ähm an ihrer Verbreitung,
an der Verbreitung gearbeitet, dass Nuttmenschen das nutzen können mit der Begründung, die Leute haben das ja nicht,
auch stimmte, ja. Es war ähm anfangs wenn ich mich nicht täusche Opt-In und ähm dann haben auch Menschen natürlich diesen nicht gemacht,
Dann wurde es Opt-Out und inzwischen haben halt alle Ausweise diese Funktion. Es hat hier, glaube ich, auch in der letzten Sendung gesagt, per Definition zehn Jahre gedauert, bis alle das haben.
Ja und in den zehn Jahren, ich glaube, die ersten fünf Jahre hat man gesagt, hat ja keiner und die zweiten fünf Jahre auch noch,
Und jetzt sagt man, ja bietet ja keiner an. Also das ähm ist dann eben äh versenkt, ne.
Es wurde übrigens in den Kommentaren auch äh festgestellt, dass äh mit der Einführung des damals noch äh NPA äh oder damals hieß der noch EPA, ne, jetzt gibt's ja die elektronische Patientenakte. Ähm,
dass es da auch ja Demonstrationen vom CCC gab oder auch ähm Stimmen im CCC gab, die sich dagegen gewehrt haben, gegen diese Form der digitalisierten Erfassung von Identitäten. Äh das ist korrekt. Ähm.
Es gab da theoretischen Angriff wenn man eben nicht,
den Reader hatte, also äh nicht den Reader, wo auch das Pinpad drauf ist, sondern nur den einfachen Reader, den ich hier auch liegen habe, äh dann könntest du theoretisch mit einer Myware natürlich die Tastatur eingaben.
Abfassen und so die PIN klauen und wie ich ja gerade gesagt hatte, die Kenntnis der Pin,
und der Besitz dieses Ausweises, also die Möglichkeit, ihn vorzuzeigen,
und die PIN einzugeben gelten dann eben als der als der Nachweis, dass du die dass du auch die Person bist, weil die PIN ja auch nur dir mitgeteilt wurde. Ähm,
ja gab es, kann ja jetzt nicht nicht nicht viel mehr zu sagen. Es gibt auch Leute, die äh in den,
Pässen, die Biometriechips äh grillen, ja, da kann man machen. Ich glaube, ich habe relativ häufig betont, dass ich äh,
nicht Lust habe,
in der in der langen Schlange zu stehen, wenn ich wenn ich in die Bundesrepublik Deutschland in Frankfurt oder München einreise bin oder ausreise, bin ich schon ganz froh, äh dass ich da an der Schnelle Geld gehen kann.
Ähm aber,
da geht es eben auch noch mal um eine Menge mehr bei diesen äh bei diesen Ausweisen zum Beispiel eben um die biometrische Erfassung, um das Speichern von Fingerabdrücken da drin
Und äh dann eben auch um die zentrale Speicherung. Das sind weitere Aspekte, die,
die wir an diesen äh neuen Pässen und neuen Personalausweisen kritisiert haben, die nicht direkt im Zusammenhang mit,
der reinen technischen Funktionalität der Smart Card stehen. Ja, also die Diskussion um Ausweisdokumente ist dann noch noch größer als äh nur.
Um die Sicherheit dieser Karte und äh darüber haben wir jetzt äh die letzten Male so ein bisschen diskutiert. Aber Tim weiß, was mir eingefallen ist.
Mein aktueller Personalausweis läuft in ein paar Jahren ab, ne? Und kann ich eigentlich so einen Ausweis von einem anderen.
Mitglied des europäischen Wirtschaftsraumes, ne? Kann ich den auch als Deutscher bei denen bekommen? Weil das wäre eine Möglichkeit ich meine, was mache ich, ich bin ja Berliner. Was mache ich mit meinem Ausweis abläuft? Bin ja erledigt.
Könnte ich dann zum Beispiel nach Dänemark, Malta, Ungarn,
Ihr Land oder Estland in irgend so ein funktionierendes Land um um dort äh nochmal ein Ausweisdokument zu bekommen.
Also das weiß ich nicht, aber ich würde das äh für durchaus ähm denkbar halten. Also wahrscheinlich musst du nach Estland,
deine Wahrscheinlichkeit da äh zu steigern.
Erfinden dir das im Zweifelsfall noch schlecht oder sagen einfach auch, das hätte eine gute Idee. Das machen wir jetzt gleich mal. Kommen sie doch Montag noch mal wieder.
Ich dachte Malta, weil die über den kannst du dir auch einfach einen Pass kaufen.
Kannst du eure ganze Staatsangehörigkeit kriegst du gleich noch dazu, ja ja.
Das Problem darf, das könnte man eigentlich zum Berlin Malta so ein mit äh fliegste oder fährst du mitm Bus und äh ihr.
So so ähm Ausweisfahrt nach Malta.
Ich lasse einfach die Autos künftig alle weiter zu fassen. Geht schneller.
Ja, aber ich meine, das ist wirklich dramatisch in Berlin, ne? Also ich meine, das grenzt schon wirklich an ähm ich weiß gar nicht, wie nennt man denn das? Das ist doch irgendwie so ein so ein so ein Notstand, ne? Ich meine, es gibt hier Gesetze, die sagen, wenn ich hierher ziehe,
Muss ich mich innerhalb von, was ist es, weiß ich nicht, sechs Wochen oder so, muss man sich melden.
Ja Tim, das ist die Berliner zu sagen, äh das Boot ist voll. Ne? Du musst dich melden.
Na ja, sie kannst du schon, aber bellen geht nicht.
Irgendwas müssen wir dem Schwaben hier entgegenhalten. Dann ich ähm.
Wat melden wollen Sie sich? Früher in der Schule bestimmt auch nicht gemeldet.
Aber das ist ja ist ja es ist ja tatsächlich so ein bisschen ähm.
Um also der es es beißt sich da wirklich bisschen als in den Schwanz und es ist es ist tatsächlich ein ein Notstand hier in Berlin. Das ist ist korrekt. Und ist auch erstaunlich, dass dir das.
Dass sie das so zelebrieren, ja und auch überhaupt nicht in also so als gegeben, das ist jetzt seit Jahren so.
Es ist einfach so. Es ist es ändert sich nichts daran. Alles völlig äh völlig verhärmt und alles alles steckt äh fest und man kann da natürlich jetzt auf Berlin,
zeigen, aber es ist halt im Großen und Ganzen, also selbst wenn's noch solche Bürgertermine zum ich melde mich mal an, woanders gibt, heißt es ja nicht, dass der Rest funktionieren würde. Also es ist einfach alles ein bisschen.
Alles ein bisschen kaputt. Dann haben wir noch was über Kaninchen gelernt. Wir haben's schon angesprochen, ne? Ja.
Ja, ich habe auch einen Fehler gemacht und zwar habe ich gesagt, Hasengraben, die Glasfaser wieder aus, stimmt nicht. Äh Hasen graben keine Löcher. Das machen Kaninchen, Mäuse, Maulwürfe, Vögel, Erdwesen,
Maulwurst grillen, äh Regenwürmer und und Hunde Urin laut Kugel.
Hundeurin kann graben.
Das ist das Ergebnis. Ich habe gegoogelt, welche Tiere krabbeln, Hundeurin greift gleich an. Es ist so.
Man lernt nie aus.
Der Anzug habe ich irgendwie äh hat die AI was falsch gepast.
Wildschweine, Igel, Füchse oder Dachse können auch äh Löcher hinterlassen?
Ja genau da hier ist also in diesem Artikel ist Hundeurin eine ähm eine Überschrift, weil,
Nur damit wir das jetzt auch sicherstellen, honorien grip keine Löcher. Er hat seine Auswirkungen, wenn der Hund mal muss, bleibt punktuell,
oft ein Stück verbrannter Rasen zurück.
Interessen an an dessen Rändern der Rasen durch den Düngeeffekt intensiv wächst.
Urin ist auch so ein Wort, das muss man echt, da muss man zweimal hingucken, bis man weiß.
Ja, ich habe auch gedacht, was ist denn eine Hundein?
Genau. Hundeorien klingt so ein bisschen wie so ein neues Medikament.
Das drehen wir denen an.
Hundeurin nehme geht's mir viel besser.
Kannst auch Eigenhundeurin nehmen. Das ist günstiger.
Häufiger als dreimal pro Tag.
Okay. Wenn wir jetzt eh schon äh bei bei der Art von Humor sind, ne.
Die ganz schlimmen Sachen rauslassen.
Können wir auch erzählen. Ich habe ähm heute durchaus Spaß gehabt, weil ich mir.
Runtergeladen habe.
Das ist eine von diesen AI-Geschichten, wo du wo du Bildbeschreibungen,
schreibst und der tut das dann malen oder oder fotografieren für dich, wie du möchtest. Kannst du unterschiedliche Stile, ne? Und ähm.
Habe das äh das war jetzt hier schon in ich bin ja immer ein bisschen spät zu den Trends. Das ist
äh ist glaube ich schon vor einiger Zeit da also war schon vor ein paar Wochen, dass sich Leute damit immer auseinandergesetzt haben. Es waren immer so also Service-Dinger, irgendwann wurde das dann released, jetzt konnte man das runterladen. Ist tatsächlich ein bisschen äh faszinierend, ne. Du lädst hier so ein bisschen Pythoncode runter.
Und dann irgendwie so ein ich weiß nicht, vier Gigabyte Modell oder sowas?
Dann brauchst du ein bisschen Rahmen. Ich glaube so acht Kigramm, geteilter Rahmen mit der Grafikkarte. Ähm was ja jetzt hier bei so einem M äheins zwei hast du nicht gesehen, Mac äh kein Problem ist?
Und dann schreibst du so Peifen lalala Text to Image, dann die Beschreibung und lässt den malen.
In Englisch formuliert.
Musst net Englisch machen, ja und dann äh ja war war ganz lustig. Dann habe ich irgendwann mal gedacht, na was malt ihr denn noch so, ne? Und dann äh,
siehste natürlich auch relativ schnell die Grenzen. Paar Sachen hat er wirklich tolle tolle Bildchen gemalt, irgendwie so Donald Trump fährt Motorrad im Wald,
Als Comicfigur dann so ein so einen wütenden Donald Trump, der mitm Motorrad durch den Wald fährt, gemalt. Das war wirklich sehr äh sehr sehr schön.
Und dann habe ich aber irgendwann festgestellt, dass der irgendwie keinen also keine nackten Menschen malen kann, ne und dann habe ich gedacht,
Also nackt funktioniert immer nicht, ne. Und dann habe ich festgestellt, dass es ein NSF so ein, so ein Safety-Image-Filter gibt. Also der die haben eingebaut so ein,
quasi NSFEKTOR und wenn das Ding irgendwie in so einen NSFW Bereich kommt, dann,
schmeißt er das Bild raus. Also habe ich die habe ich das mal rausgepatcht,
und geguckt, was er dann so malt, ne und das funktioniert dann also an einigen Stellen immer noch nicht, also immer wenn du Schlafzimmer sagst, dann dann verschwinden die nackten Menschen, zumindest die nackten Männer,
Frauen gibt's da noch, im Schlafzimmer schon. Dann habe ich irgendwann gedacht, okay, dann machen wir mal in der Küche.
Frauen sind nicht sozusagen.
Ich habe halt so ein bisschen versucht, ich habe halt mal so ein bisschen stichprobartig, dass Leer das Lehrmaterial äh von dieser von diesem Modell so ein bisschen ergründet.
Dann habe ich irgendwann festgestellt, okay, wenn du jetzt nackte Männer in der Küche machst, dann,
sind hier auch äh wie der Herr Gott sie schuf ja und äh da sind aber teilweise sogar also ganz lustige Artefakte dann auch ähm drin und dann habe ich,
dann habe ich halt äh gedacht, ja okay, egal, jetzt machen wir andere Sachen, ne, weil irgendwie lustig mal zu sehen, wie der wie dieser nackte Menschen halt. Aber
Aber jetzt ist es halt so, dass er andauernd nackte Menschen sind,
weil seit ich diese Filter ausgebaut habe, auch wenn ich andere Sachen äh malen möchte. Aber mein meine Stichprobe ist noch zu klein, aber ich hatte auf jeden Fall Spaß und ich war auch tatsächlich erstaunt, ähm.
Der macht das so in ungefähr einer Minute zehn Sekunden, eine Minute, 15 Sekunden ist der mit so einem Bild fertig,
Das ist schon ähm also hier auf so einem Laptop, ne? Das äh liegt natürlich an der an der absoluten Überlegenheit,
Apple-Arm-Prozessoren, aber insgesamt schon faszinierend. Ich hätte gedacht, dass das oder ich wusste einfach nicht, wie lange das dauern würde, also.
Das heißt, wenn man diesen NSFW-Filter ausschaltet, dann ist auf einmal alles voll mit Pimmelchen sozusagen.
Nicht ganz, aber.
Braucht, also diesen Filter um überhaupt sinnvolle Ergebnisse zu bekommen,
Kann man sich ja nur vorstellen, aus was für einem Datenmaterial sich dieses System dem ganzen Internet und das ganze Internet ist halt einfach voll.
Irgendwie Nacktheit und äh wenn du die nicht von vornherein rausnimmst, dann bleibt überhaupt nix äh Angenehmes mehr über.
Es ist äh das kann schon tolle Sachen machen. Aber ich habe dann nämlich auch, um mal so ein bisschen zu gucken, wo das denn sein Lehrmaterial her hat
auf so eine ähm habe ich gegoogelt, was denn was ist denn für Pornoseiten gibt. Da findet man ja auf Netzpolitik org immer Artikel drüber und ähm habe dann mal
einfach die Videobeschreibungen eingegeben, die jetzt nicht so reich an ähm.
Also wenn du wenn du wenn du ein ordentliches Bild haben willst, ich habe ganz viel versucht Vladimir Putin wie er kleine Dosen mit Gas im Supermarkt verkauft
Das das konnte das Ding so mal gut, mal schlecht, ne? Der kommt ja auch immer ein anderes Bild raus. Aber wenn du jetzt Pornhaubtitel da eingibst,
kommt immer ungefähr das raus, äh was äh.
Zu sehen ist.
Gewisse Ewigkeit zu dem Video ist zu erkennen, ja.
Ich sage dir, sackt sich einfach den ganzen Poren. Hast du mal nach Hundearien gefragt.
Ich glaube, die haben so einen Filter auf ähm also wenn jetzt äh äh ähm hör mal, böse Worte benutzt und äh ich.
Ist doch kein böses Wort.
Also Doc Urin äh Doc Urianating, ihr müsst sie mal ausprobieren, kann ich mal hier gleich kurz machen.
Aber wenn du böse Wörter benutzt, dann funktioniert's nicht und ich glaube nämlich, dass die das Lehrmaterial, also totaler Quatsch jetzt, jetzt kommen wieder die Korrekturen, ich mache das ja nur, damit wir wieder Feedback kriegen, erzähle ich das. Ähm da äh,
wenn du jetzt wenn explizite Begriffe vorkommen, dann äh ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit groß, dass einfach gar nix kommt. Also du musst du musst es halt umschreiben,
ja. Was soll man sagen Hundeurin? So ich mache mal Dog Pis.
Läuft jetzt grade, mal gucken. Aber wir können ja mal zum zum Thema kommen.
Ja, ich freue mich sowieso die ganze Zeit, was das jetzt eigentlich mit Netzpolitik zu tun hat. Irgendwie kommen wir vom Thema ab. Kann das sein?
Ich wollte nur meine meine AI-Art äh die werden natürlich jetzt als NFT angeboten.
Kann uns keiner vorwerfen, dass wir uns hier nicht mit moderner Technologie beschäftigen würden. Man muss ja auch irgendwie dran bleiben am äh Thema und das äh ist wichtig.
Außerdem,
Uns äh später dann so hier unsere äh Themenblöcke machen und irgendwann quatschen wir ja nur noch fünf Worte rein und dann entstehen vollständige Lochbuchnetzpolitiksegmente. Da müssen wir nicht so viel Zeit mit diesem Podcast.
Ja genau, vielleicht können wir den einfach vielleicht tippen, können wir bitte ähm einfach.
Modell trainieren aus den anderen 437 Sendungen.
Vor allem wir haben wir haben ja die Shownotes und wir können ja wir können ja die Show Notes nehmen und einfach alles, was in den in den verlinkten Seiten, in den Shownotes steht, ist halt Input.
Audiodetails ist Outfit, dann sollte das lernen und dann müssen wir nur noch die Links sammeln und ähm.
Das hätten wir gerne bis nächste Woche hier. Ihr wär bestimmt so AI Spezialisten. Er setzt uns mal durch ein Script, ja? Das äh wäre doch mal also ich werd's auf jeden Fall lustig.
Das wird bestimmt funktionieren.
Warte mal, jetzt ist schon fertig. Mal gucken, was er hier gemacht hat. Oben.
Also ich habe jetzt Hundeurin, einen Hundolinspender, habe ich jetzt mal mahlen lassen. Ja, da kam nämlich jetzt nix raus, weil ich habe Piss geschrieben, das das kennt ihr nicht. Da musst du.
Fashester. Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Unsere Hörer eigentlich schon drauf hingewiesen, dass wir serienmäßig immer mit Kapitelmarken kommen.
Und mit in denen ihr jetzt schöne Bilder sehen könnt, alle erwähnten Bilder äh,
Nee, das geht auch wirklich nicht. Sind Sachen bei rausgekommen. Was was nicht so gut funktioniert hat, war äh Känguru, dass einen Nazi boxt, aber äh.
Du kannst ja mal unsere Sendungstitel einfach mal da reinlaufen lassen und mal gucken, was dabei rauskommt.
Also was auf jeden Fall funktioniert ist äh,
Ich sage gar nichts mehr. My Donald Trump aufm Motorrad im Wald ist wirklich super. Den machen wir als den würde ich echt gerne als Bild. Ich hier, das ist wirklich super. Also der ist auch gut getroffen.
Hier guck dir den mal an. Ja okay, gut.
Komm, lass uns zu unseren Dystopien zurückkehren.
Ja genau, also äh geht natürlich so nicht weiter, weil wir brauchen Vorratsdatenspeicherung, aber der Donald Trump ist wirklich gut, oder.
Der ist wirklich super.
Der ist gut. Ähm für eure Vorzeitenspeicherung, weil am 20. September, das ist in 13 Tagen.
Wird, der EuGH über die ähm.
Über die äh deutsche Regelung zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung entscheiden. Insgesamt ist die Vorratsdatensprechung in Deutschland gerade ausgesetzt,
Weil mehrere äh Verwaltungsgerichte zu der Erkenntnis gelangt sind, dass die zweitausendfünfzehn,
beschlossenen Vorgaben nicht mit europäischem Recht vereinbar sind.
So, am 20. September fällt jetzt der Europäische Gerichthof über die deutsche Regelung sein Urteil und wir haben ja eine Koalition aus SPD, Grünen und FDP. Die haben,
in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben, die Regelungen zur Fortseitenspeicherung so auszugestalten, dass Daten rechtssicher,
Anlass bezogen und durch richterlichen Beschluss gespeichert werden können. Ähm.
Diese diese Worte haben ja eine Bedeutung, rechtssicher okay also muss,
klar sein, dass das Gesetz nicht wieder durch höhere Gerichte oder also durch durch die äh durch das Verfassungsgericht oder der EuGH kassiert wird.
Anlass bezogen heißt,
in Abgrenzung zu Massenüberwachung, also auf spezifische Personen bezogen und durch richterlichen Beschluss heißt eben auch aufgrund eines spezifischen Anlasses, ja? Ähm,
das kann, so wie es formuliert ist, eigentlich so etwas sein wie,
wo man also sagt okay, wir speichern diese Daten erstmal.
Aber sie sind vor dem Zugriff geschützt,
und Sie werden Sie verfallen, zum Beispiel nach wenigen Tagen und dann kann aber eine, wenn jetzt eine Straftat begangen wird.
Ein richterlicher Beschluss sagen. Dieser Anschluss er unterfällt jetzt, unterliegt jetzt der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, deswegen werden diese Daten jetzt aufbewahrt und für die Zukunft,
weiter gesammelt, aber das ist dann eben Anlass bezogen, weil so ist ja irgendetwas gegeben haben, warum eine Richterin sich dazu entscheidet, diese Daten ähm haben zu wollen.
Und äh nicht mehr in Abgrenzung dazu äh eine Massenüberwachung, die jetzt die gesamte Bevölkerung immer alle betreffen würde. Und.
Eigentlich wartet die Ampelkoalition, so war der Plan darauf, dass sie das EU äh das EuGH-Urteil bekommen,
können ne, was sind denn die Grenzen des Machbaren unter einer demokratischen Verfassung oder dem, was der, was aus europäischer Ebene noch dazukommt und
Dann wollten sie dieses Ding nehmen und quasi als äh ja einfach nur, um sicherzustellen, dass ihre Quickfußregelung dem nicht widerspricht.
Jetzt kommt aber Nancy Feser 14 Tage vor dem Urteil und sagt, nee äh wir brauchen das jetzt und,
natürlich kann da ein können da eigentlich alle nur den Kopf äh schütteln. Ähm,
wie die Mysterien arbeiten ja schon an der äh Alternative ja also muss ja auch klar. Zum Beispiel das Bundesjustizministerium ähm dass er auch dafür zuständig ist in in meiner
Wahrnehmung und da sagte äh,
der Jörn Pohl, der Mitarbeiter von äh Konstantin von Notz, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, wegen vieler Nachfragen aus aktuellem Anlass zu Fortzeitensprechung. Der Koalitionsvertrag könnte eindeutiger nicht sein. Das,
Bundesjustizministerium arbeitet bereits wie zwischen den Ministerien abgestimmt an der Alternative die kommt,
in Kürze und also die eigenen Koalitionspartner verstehen nicht, warum Nancy Fesa das jetzt macht und ich verstehe es auch nicht und ich bin noch nicht mal.
Koalitionspartner.
Ja und vor allem hat sie ja vor ein paar Monaten noch was anderes erzählt.
Richtig, Konstantin Kuhle nur um auch die FDP hier zu würdigen ähm sagt er auch nein,
die Ampelkoalition wird die anlasslose Speicherung beerdigen, fertig, ja? Auch das sei gewürdigt, ja, Konstantin,
Coole ist der stellvertretende Vorsitzende der ähm FDP Bundestag,
für Süd Niedersachsen und der Generalsekretär und Rechtsanwalt ist er auch noch und ich würde vorsichtig sagen, einer von denen in der FDP, die so,
vom Schlager eines äh Jimmy Schulz tatsächlich auch ein bisschen Ahnung von diesem Digital Thema haben, ja.
Ähm und im Juni ja, ich glaube, war das im Juni oder sogar im Juli äh,
Anfang Juni hat sie groß gesagt, ja wir wollen nur IP-Adressen speichern ähm das war also diese Diskussion mit der,
Verlängerung der Bestandsdatenauskunft, wo also ein längerer Zeitraum ermöglicht werden soll, wo Strafverfolgungsbehörden sich an,
Internetservice Provider wenden und sagen am soundso vielten September,
wer hatte folgende IP-Adresse? Und diese, auch das haben wir ja schon diskutiert, weil wir's auch mehrmals, weil ich ja selber sogar mit Nancy Failser darüber gesprochen habe bei Markus Lanz, wo sie sich dafür eingesetzt hat, ja und es ist wirklich.
Nicht nicht so ganz nachvollziehbar, warum sie jetzt ausrechnet in dieser Zeit, während die Koalition etwas anderem arbeitet, nach vorne stimmt und sagt, sie will Vorzahlenspeicherung. Es ist,
Und ich glaube, es hat was damit zu tun, dass der Laden auch immer noch äh Bundesministerium für Inneres und äh Heimat heißt.
Die hat da einfach echt nicht aufgeräumt.
Ja, also die ist wohl geblitzt worden. Also die ist in so einen Raum geführt worden,
Und äh dann macht's gut so. Und äh dann erinnerst du dich halt nicht mehr, was vor drei Monaten war und dann kriegst du das irgendwie so übern Lautsprecher äh durchgesagt und dann.
Thema so mit den Fingern und dann wacht sie wieder auf. Und dann fängt die Diskussion wieder von vorne an. Das machen sie glaube ich mit allen in Ministern.
Also anders ist das wirklich nicht zu erklären, ne. Ich meine bei den meisten Leuten, die da in letzter Zeit so reinmarschiert sind in dieses Ministerium, da hast du auch vorher nicht nichts Gutes geahnt, aber ähm ist schon faszinierend,
Ja, was da so los ist, ne? Und ich habe ja hier auch schon gesagt, dass ich den Eindruck habe, dass in Sachen Chatkontrolle und so.
Ebenfalls, da der der eine die eine oder andere Wendung äh von Nancy Phaser,
kommen wird und ich frage mich ehrlich, wenn also ich weiß nicht, seit wie vielen Jahren die SPD ja wirklich für dieses Umkippen,
und Verraten bekannt ist, ne? Ist ja schon relativ lange, dass man den Sozialdemokraten und Sozialdemokratinnen einen gewissen Hang äh zum Umkippen nachsagt.
Und ich als Sozialdemokrat äh wäre ich so mit Sozialdemokrat fühle ich mich ja dafür davor hüten ähm diesen diesen Ruf gerecht zu werden.
Alles ja geblitzt worden, deswegen weißt du es ja.
Gibt's schöne Lieder zu. Aber okay ähm kommen wir zu Cyberwall.
Es gibt eine,
Also machen wir bleiben wir mal beim Cyber-Award zwischen Russland äh und der Ukraine. Da gab's ja immerhin äh ein paar äh interessante Meldungen,
Und zwar mal was zum Lachen. Ähm offenbar haben Leute, die,
russische Taxivermittlungs-App von Jandex.
Gehackt oder infiltriert oder was auch immer. Äh Jannex ist ja so, würde sagen, dass das russische Google, wer das am am besten beschrieben?
Ja also zumindest eine der wichtigen Suchmaschinen, wenn ich die wichtigste Suchmaschine na ja, auf jeden Fall äh haben sich äh einige findige äh Leute äh dieser Back-End-Systeme der Taxis,
ähm bemächtigt,
und ja, dann paar Aufträge äh rausgehauen und die führten dazu, dass für dich,
Alle Taxis oder zumindest große Mengen an Taxis alle an dieselbe äh an den selben Einsatzort geschickt worden.
Wie heißt das äh der Cut Husosov äh Prospekt. Dort kam's dann zu einer ungewöhnlichen Autoanhäufung. Ja.
Ja
Wegen der gefälschten Bestellung hätten Leute teilweise mehr als zwei Stunden im Stau gestanden, äh,
Jandex hat gesagt, wer nur 40 Minuten im Stau gewesen das Schöne an dem Stau ist, aber halt schon, der besteht halt nur aus Taxis. Ich weiß nicht ob das ob das in,
in Moskau normal ist, aber äh ja, das äh das ist schon ganz lustig, würde ich sagen, ja. Traurig natürlich auch, dass das,
natürlich in keiner Weise irgendwie zu vergleichen ist mit dem.
Was Russland äh im Krieg gegen die äh Ukraine macht. Deswegen kommen wir mal zu einem etwas,
würde man sagen besseren Beispiel, dass man schon eher im Bereich des Cyberwall anordnen könnte,
Denn mit gefälschten Social Media Accounts von attraktiven Frauen wurden russische Soldaten geködert und so gelangten deren Standortdaten anders,
ukrainische Militär und daraufhin gab es dann Artillerieangriffe,
auf ähm diese Orte, wo die sich aufgehalten haben.
Es ist wirklich superperfide, aber auch nicht wirklich überraschend, ne. Ähm die.
Gibt halt so bestimmte Momente im Leben, wo Menschen bereit sind.
Ihre, wie soll man sagen, ihre Operational Security ein wenig schleifen zu lassen weil äh man sich verspricht, dadurch äh andere Weihungen zu erhalten,
und ähm wir wissen alle, das gibt dann so äh bestimmte hormonelle Zustände in den ja,
vielleicht auch irgendwann alles äh egal ist, vor allem wenn man irgendwie schon seit Monaten da durch die Erde robbt und so weiter. Na ja und dann,
Darüber halt bekommen und Ukrainer sind auch wirklich ziemlich gut darin äh solche Orte zu melden. Es gibt ja da so diverse Apps wo Bürger
quasi Tipps geben können, sagen können, so hier ist folgendes etcetera.
Und darüber sammeln sie halt die ganze Zeit Tipps ein und dann können sie es eben in ihren Kommando und Kontrollstruktur noch relativ schnell zuleiten. Es gibt da ja da so eine,
interessante, digitale Infrastruktur, womit dann äh automatisch den äh nicht gelegene Einsatzgruppe,
quasi ermittelt wird, die dort zuschlagen könnte, also die gerade nicht mit was anderem beschäftigt ist. Das ist so ein bisschen so ja auch so ein bisschen wie so ein Taxivermittlung, ne, so ein bisschen so U-Bahn-mäßig.
Und äh ja und dann ja die wissen halt mit was die,
ausgerüstet sind et cetera und dann geht das halt in dem Moment an irgendeine Artillerie äh Posten und dann sind die Koordinaten da auch schnell übermittelt und dann scheppert's, ne.
Ja, also offen.
Klassisches Computerrisiko.
Eine Person von dieser LK-Gruppe sagt, die Russen wollen immer ficken
Sie schicken dem Mädchen eine Menge Scheiße, um zu beweisen, dass sie Krieger sind. Aufgrund der Fotos konnten sie dann den Stützpunkt genau verorten
Und den haben sie dann im ukrainischen Militär weitergegeben und wenige Tage später hätten Kiers Truppen den Stützpunkt,
mit Artillerieangriffen zerstört. Erinnert mich auch ein bisschen an diese ähm.
Was war das denn? Irgend so eine Sport-App, wo die Leute.
Wo die Soldaten äh äh Training äh gemacht haben, diese Fitness-Apps benutzt haben.
Fitness-App, wo dann irgendwie in der Wüste auf einmal die Fitness-App sagt, ey hör mal, da kannst du echt super laufen, einfach immer im Kreis, ja und das war,
Das waren dann die nicht nichtöffentlichen Militärstützpunkte oder die nicht verzeichneten Militärstützpunkte in Afghanistan oder so.
Na ja, die war dann irgendwie auf Runtastic oder sonst irgendwelchen.
Genau, irgend so einer App war das, ja wie ich weiß nicht mehr genau, welche das war, aber.
Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, also es ist schon faszinierend, was jetzt so ein also die ganzen Smartphones.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich gerne eine Armee hätte, die mit Smartphones irgendwie ein anderes Land ich hätte eh keine Armee, aber und wenn, dann wäre sie nicht im anderen Land, aber die mit Smartphones rumrennen zu lassen.
Ja, also in den ersten Tagen des des des Krieges. Ich weiß nicht, wie die Situation sich jetzt darstellt. Es ging da mal
ist jetzt auch eine nicht wirklich eine,
identifizierte Informationen, aber es ging halt solche Maps rum, ne, wo halt äh aus den ukrainischen Mobilfunknetzwerken sie einfach gut Karten machen konnten mit so russischen SIM-Karten, die sich irgendwie in ihr Netz eingebucht haben.
Natürlich auch schön die Truppenkonzentration und Truppenbewegung nachvollziehen können. So wie man das mit Autos macht, um den Verkehr äh zu messen, ne.
Also das geht sicherlich sehr einfach, das kann ich dir auch garantieren. Ich bin ja in diesem Bereich tätig und das äh das ist wirklich eine der einfacheren Übungen.
Na ja, das ist überhaupt gar kein äh Problem, wobei diese ganzen Verkehrsmeldungen von äh Google und so weiter wurden ja für die Ukraine abgeschaltet.
Aber die Mobilfunknetze solange
würde es ja davon ausgehen, dass deine Regulationsbehörden, deine Aufsichtsbehörden guten Draht
zu den Mobilfunknetzen haben oder auch notfalls das Innenministerium da reingeht und sagt, Leute, ich habe mir überlegt, wir brauchen jetzt Vorratsdatenspeicherung für russische äh ähm Imz
und das äh glaube ich, das geht dann schon ganz schnell, ne. Abgesehen davon, dass hier offenbar auch äh ernsthaft über diese Telefonnetze telefoniert haben, was man ja noch nicht mal in seinem in seinem Heimatland macht.
Ja, ja, also äh ich würde sogar davon ausgehen, dass es in der Ukraine alles schon Next Level ist.
Ja also äh diese die planen ihre gesamte Telekommunikationsinfrastruktur schon seit längerem in Hinblick auf einen möglichsten mögliches Kriegsszenario.
Also da sind äh Glasfaseranschlüsse wirklich bis ins letzte Dorf gelegt worden,
um einfach äh jederzeit überall auch ein Command und Kontrollposten aufzusetzen. Man möchte sich überhaupt nicht vorstellen, wie das ist, wenn mal einer in Brandenburg oder in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern einmarschiert,
Also.
LTE, da haben wir 5G an jeder Milchkanne.
Von wegen wir kriegen da immer wieder erzählt, dass es an der Milchkanne nicht erforderlich ist.
Ja, aber so macht man das richtig. So pass auf, wenn der wenn der Russe nach nach Brandenburg kommt.
Da ist nix mit Tinder. Ihr wisst, da ist auch nix mit Google Map. Die verfahren sich. Die fahren an Berlin vorbei nach äh Hannover. So verwirrst du den Feind.
Toll.
So China also.
Ich finde es ja immer sehr schön, wenn Leute sich über Hacking beschweren, da ähm China beschwert sich über ähm aus den USA.
Das ist allerdings was Neues. Also normalerweise hast du ja immer so ja! Wir haben,
hunderttausend Hucking Angriffe pro Minute äh von von den Chinesen haben wir ja ist ja wissen wir ja alle, aber ist ja ganz klar hier, Cyber und jetzt beschweren sich äh chinesische Offizielle.
Dass äh ähm die USA spezifisch die NSA,
zehntausende Angriffe auf Netzwerkziele in China in den letzten Jahren begangen hätte, unter anderem hätten sie versucht die North Western Politechal University,
in wahrscheinlich spricht man in der die Stadt aus.
Ähm angegriffen, denn diese hat auch äh wird von der chinesischen.
Ministerium für Industrie und Informationstechnologie,
gefördert insbesondere im Bereich der Luft. Und Raumfahrttechnik macht natürlich schon Sinn.
Dass die NSA sich dafür interessiert, was für Forschung in der Luft-und Raumfahrttechnik in spezifisch von chinesischen Ministerien geförderten Universitäten äh stattfindet. Offenbar hätten sie dort 140 Gigabyte
von ähm sehr wertvollen Daten extrahiert und äh die NSA hat aber auf eine Anfrage nicht reagiert, wer hätte
gedacht, nein, die hat die E-Mail äh übersehen. Ähm.
Wundert mich jetzt nicht äh interessant ist, dass China sich jetzt darüber,
beschwert, ja? Das das ist tatsächlich nach meiner Wahrnehmung eher neu ähm,
und das hat potenziell auch einen strategischen ähm.
Dann gibt es,
eine kleine Recherche der Süddeutschen Zeitung, Jannis Prühl, Benedikt Heubl und Simon Hurtz, äh die,
festgestellt haben,
so gefälschte SZ-Videos gab und sich das mal weiter dem dem hinterher recherchiert haben. Ähm,
weil es da Videos gibt mit einem SZ-Logo oben rechts drin. Ein gefälschte Videos, pro-russische Propaganda, wie Sie sagen, stehen auch nicht auf den auf der echten Webseite der SZ, sondern auf gefälschten Seiten. Also die,
Leute versuchen die SZ zu fälschen?
Mit dem Logo und so weiter, das ist dann nachempfunden oder vielleicht einfach sogar kopiert. Sie beurteilen das als teils täuschend echt, teils dilettantisch.
Sie haben ähnliche Nachrichtenseiten gefunden, die Spiegel-T-Online, Bild, Welt und Faz Nachbauen und,
eben echte Fake-Videos,
also echt Effekt wie das Fake-Videos verbreiten die echt aussehen. Man findet aber gleichzeitig auf den Seiten Rechtschreibfehler und ungelenke Formulierungen werden also,
wie nennt man das? Oder so, ne? Also dass du dass du Domains registriert, die ähnlich aussehen,
Süddeutsche Punkt M E statt Süddeutsche DE nennen sie als Beispiel,
unvorsichtiger Nutzer oder wenn ihr zu Link vertwitterst oder so äh dann ist es relativ wahrscheinlich, dass es jemand nicht beim ersten. Blick merkt.
Und dann äh werden die Videos oder diese Seiten irgendwie über Twitter verbreitet.
Was ich aber auch sehr spannend finde, ist, dass das jetzt in Ruhe analysiert haben, bisschen geschaut haben, hier sind,
kurze Videos, die gehen davon aus, dass es ja eine Softwareautomatisierung gibt, dass beispielsweise das gleiche Video, einmal mit einem,
Spiegel-Logo mit einem SZ-Logo versehen wird und dann auf diese Domains gepusht wird. Und sie kommen aber, was ich auch ganz spannend finde, trotz all dieser Tricks
zu dem Fazit, trotz all dieser Tricks hält sich der messbare Erfolg der Desinformation in Grenzen, man findet zwar viele Fake-Accounts, aber kaum Reaktionen auf die Videos, die sie verbreiten,
Stichprobenartige Überprüfung zeigen, dass die Links zu den Fälschungen selten bis nie von echten Menschen geteilt werden.
Auch auf Telegram spielen die Fakes keine Rolle. Dort existieren etliche große Gruppen und Kanäle, die sich inhaltlich auf russischer Propaganda-Linie bewegen, trotzdem tauchen die nachgebauten Sorten Seiten dort fast nie auf.
Allem Anschein nach war der Aufwand,
für die Kampagne größer als ihr Ertrag und das finde ich äh deswegen bemerkenswert, weil sie's wenigstens mal sagen, ja, weil sie's analysiert haben und es benennen
und äh sich auch die Mühe machen, mal zu gucken, was ist hier los, das einerseits aufzudecken, wie sind die wohl technisch vorgegangen
und andererseits aber dann auch mal zu schauen, haben die denn irgendeinen Erfolg gehabt? Und ich finde diese Form von Analyse solcher Phänomene,
tatsächlich sehr, sehr, sehr notwendig, weil wir ja in, wenn ich's vorsichtig ausdrücken soll, ähm eine.
Hohe Sorge haben und immer viel Panik machen und dann gibt's Bot und dann ist ein Fake News im Internet und so. Aber das mal in Ruhe zu analysieren,
zumindest zu sagen, ja wahrscheinlich sind irgendwelche Telegram-Kanäle von irgendwelchen Spinnern wirklich ein größeres Problem als irgendwelche Fakeseiten im Internet. Ja,
fällt aber dann eben auch offensichtlich unter das unter den Hut,
pro-russischer Propaganda-Versuche. Ob das jetzt von der äh von von der russischen Regierung ist,
weiß ich nicht zu beurteilen, wahrscheinlich eher also weiß ich nicht, haben sie haben sie mutmaßen sie selber auch nicht drüber.
Na ja gut, diesmal ist ja keine Neuigkeit, dass äh da von staatlicher Seite massiv auch in solche Operationen ähm investiert wird und es geht halt auch
vielleicht nicht unbedingt immer da drum, dass etwas messbar ist, sondern es wird einfach nur,
Unsicherheit gesät. Ja du klappst das einfach alles voll mit irgendwas und diese Videos zeigen ja auch schön wie wenig man liefern muss oder,
Weiß nicht, ob Sie das zeigen, aber zumindest merkt man, dass Sie sich jetzt nicht total viel Mühe meinen geben zu müssen, ne, haben wir immer noch,
Worte drin findet, weil äh das halt einfach alles so scheißehaufen sind, die an die Wand geworfen werden und irgendwas bleibt halt immer hängen. So und darum geht's ja. Es geht um diese diese Zerrüttung des Diskurses
immer wieder diesen Moment äh herzustellen bei den Leuten, dass sie sich sagen,
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was ich glauben soll. So und dann äh eben auch,
quasi echte Berichte von der Süddeutschen Zeitung halt auch nicht mehr zur Kenntnis nehmen, weil die sehen ja das Logo und dann so, ah ja.
War letzte Mal schon so ein Quatsch und jetzt erzählen sie mir noch mal was anderes und,
ob das jetzt wirkungsvoll ist, weiß ich nicht. Zumindest ist es bemerkenswert, dass Sie aber auch nichts unversuch lassen,
Also ist wirklich mit allen Möglichkeiten versucht wird auf wenn's auch nur eine Teilöffentlichkeit ist äh.
Darauf einzuwirken und in irgendeiner Form für Verwirrung und Desinformation zu sorgen.
So viel zum Cyber-Rohr. Dann gibt es jetzt eine also 222 ist ja sowieso das Jahr von Linux on the Desktop,
und und von Proof of Steak by IFA.
Ja, haben wir gehört.
Ne beides ähnlich lange schon in Aussicht gestellt? Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube seit zwei, drei Jahren reden die bei Ethereum davon, dass sie von dem,
Modell auf das Proof of State Modell umwandern wollen, haben das immer wieder verschoben. Ähm Effeeum,
die Blockchain,
die mit nicht nur quasi die nicht nur Überweisungen kann, sondern eben auch mit anderen Worten Code in der Blockchain.
Oder in der auch die viele NFTs zu Hause sind, ähm die also insgesamt sehr viel,
Ja äh Anwendungsreicher ist ähm von von dem, was sie was sie irgendwie kann, ja. Man muss ja.
Manche ist es ein Währungssystem. Für andere ist es der vielleicht langsamste Computer der Welt.
Genau, da wurde ich ja auch korrigiert. Ich glaube, ich hatte die letzten Sendungen schon gesagt, ne, weil Bruchstücke eines Raspberry-Piece, aber darum geht's gar nicht unbedingt. Ähm.
Positiv zu beurteilen ist, immerhin, dass das Einzige, was wir jetzt hier auch diskutieren, immerhin wollen sie für den Scheiß nicht mehr,
den Planeten abfackeln und wollen dadurch, dass sie von Proof of Work,
gehen, den Energieverbrauch der ganzen Angelegenheit massiv absenken.
Ja, also den Planeten, glaube ich, wollen sie immer noch abfackeln ähm durch das Finanzinstrument, was dort geschaffen wird, aber.
Andere, aber nicht mehr nicht mit direkt.
Ja genau, nicht nur noch mittelbar, nicht unmittelbar. Äh vielleicht sollte man ein bisschen Begriffsklärung äh treiben für Leute, die da nicht so täglich äh drin sind, also ähm ich sage mal
äh ist halt sozusagen das zweitwichtigste Krypto.
System, was so aufm Markt ist äh nach Bitcoin, was ja das alles hat äh so ein bisschen äh ins Laufen gebracht hat so und ähm,
Ja und es funktioniert im Prinzip erstmal ähnlich, hat halt ein paar
Features und beide benutzen eben dieses Modell des Proof of Work, also den Arbeitsnachweis nicht von Menschen, sondern von Computern, um einen spezifischen Problem zu lösen, das will man nämlich,
neues Geld ausgibt und sozusagen unter den Armen verteilt. Ähm das
dann das irgendwie fair getan wird, dass halt man sicherstellen kann, dass jetzt nicht äh mehrere Gruppen Geld empfangen, aber es ist am Ende immer äh dieselbe Person.
Und um das Problem zu lösen, was so ein ganz grundlegendes Problem bei solchen dezentralen Geldsystemen ist.
Wurde eben für Bitcoin dieses Proof of Work geschaffen und das war am Anfang noch ein bisschen harmlos, weil da redeten wir noch irgendwie über Computer, die fünf Minuten lang mal kurz was rechnen, aber dadurch, dass halt,
Die Anforderung an diesen Rechenaufwand immer weiter steigen muss, weil die Computer immer schneller wurden, et cetera.
Ist das mittlerweile so ausgeartet
der Gesamtenergieverbrauch von all diesen Krypto-Assets irgendwo ja im im Staatenbereich liegt, je nachdem wen man fragt und wie man rechnet äh irgendwas so zwischen Niederlande und äh
Belgien und das ist natürlich eine Menge Holz und äh das geht so nicht und Proof of Stake ist so der Versuch
dieses Entscheidungsmodell auf etwas anderem basieren zu lassen, nämlich dass man quasi Geld,
Nämlich dieses Krypto äh Geld selbst nimmt quasi einzahlt und sagt so äh ich
wäre bereit hier den nächsten Block zu verifizieren für euch alle und dann wird so eine Lotterie ausgelobt wer denn das jetzt macht aber da kann nicht einfach jeder dran teilnehmen, weil du musst halt,
um daran teilnehmen zu können, einmal einen relativ großen Betrag. In dem Fall handelt es sich um zweiunddreißig,
was nach aktuellem Kurs was ist? Weißt du das?
Mal anderthalbtausend, also.
Eineinhalbtausend.
48tausend ungefähr gerade.
Ja, okay, also knapp 50tausend Euro, sagen wir mal. Also nicht nichts. Für manche Leute vielleicht,
wirklich nicht viel und jetzt gestern wurde der erste technische Schritt,
eingeleitet äh von zweien der diese Umstellung von dem alten Modell auf das neue Modell für das E-Sero-Netzwerk einleiten soll.
Könnte es sein, wenn das alles funktioniert. Ja, dass zumindest dieser enorme Energieverbrauch so nicht mehr stattfindet könnte.
Jetzt also statt jetzt das also was bedeutet das für du musst ja trotzdem ein ein Anreiz geben, dass Leute deine Blockchain stabilisieren wollen,
und dieser dieser Anreiz sollte möglichst verteilt sein. Jetzt kommt,
der bis bestehenden Zeit konnte man also sagen, kauf dir Grafikkarten,
und diese Grafikkarten werden dir wenn du Glück hast einen Ertrag bringen, weil das was die Grafikkarten in ITA abwerfen oder was oder die was die Hardware in IFA abwirft, ist ist,
mehr als Strom und ähm,
deiner und Wertverlust der Hardware, ja das das sollte dann also das IFA Mining attraktiv machen, macht auch das Bitcoin Mining attraktiv und jetzt ist es also.
Du kriegst auch Belohnungen dafür, dass du den Block äh signieren durftest, aber dass du dass du das darfst.
Entscheidet sich durch eine Lotterie ne, durch eine zufällige Zahl. Also du wirst zufällig ausgewählt
Jetzt ist natürlich die Sache, je mehr du stakst, desto wahrscheinlicher ist es auch. Du hast also immer noch einen Anreiz zu sagen, na ja okay, ich haue da nicht nur 32 IFA rein, sondern,
äh vierundsechzig,
oder hundertachtundzwanzig oder sonst was und dann sagen sie jetzt aber hier na ja auf ihrer äh Seite aktuell ist irgendwie so was wie, was habe ich gerade geschaut,
ein paar Milliarden sind halt gestaket aktuell ähm und das soll schützen gegen den.
Gegen den 50-Prozent-Angriff, weil jetzt wahrscheinlich keiner so viele Milliarden aufbringen wird,
die Hälfte von Isar zu kontrollieren. Ähm.
Gleichzeitig aber trotzdem ein Modell, wo wer mehr Geld hat, halt auch mehr davon kriegt, ne. Also die die kriegen das schon ganz gut hin, äh sich in das existierende Wirtschaftssystem einzugliedern, würde ich, würde ich sagen.
Total dezentral.
Ist es ist äh also für deren Anwendungszweck müssen die sich nur darum kümmern, dass halt ähm,
Sie haben 14 Millionen IFA sind gerade also 4zehn Millionen Mal 1600 Euro sind schon echt ein da sind auf jeden Fall Milliarden und dafür müsstest du die Hälfte kontrollieren aber.
Sie sagen halt jetzt dieser Steak, den du da gibst, der wird das ist auch das Geld, was du ins Risiko gehst, wenn du nämlich Mist machst. Und wenn deine Note nicht ähm online ist, zahlst du quasi,
Strafen,
Und wenn du was, wenn du irgendwie Blöcke signierst oder eine Blockauswahl triffst, die insgesamt potenziell geeignet wäre, die IFA
Blockchain zu destabilisieren, dann wirst du halt quasi auch bestraft. Also dieses Geld legst du halt hin,
und sagst, ich bin ehrlich. Und wenn du nicht ehrlich oder wenn man dir nachweist, dass du nicht ehrlich bist,
oder nicht deinen Job ordentlich machst, dann sind Teile,
oder potenziell das gesamte Geld eben auch weg, was die andere Seite ist, was hier der der Anreiz sein soll, dich es eben unattraktiv zu machen.
Ähm unehrlich zu sein.
Mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Hä?
Wenn du also wenn du dich auf eine wenn der wenn du als Volidator auf eine Weise gehandelt hast, die äh die Integrität des Systemes verwirren oder unterbrechen kann, dann wird.
Dir ein Teil deines ähm Steaks geslascht.
Sodass du einen graduellen bis vollständigen Verlust deines E-Surfers. E-Ferriss hast und das ist irreversibel, weil sie auf der Blockchain.
Wenn du ähm offline bist, kriegst du auch Strafen dafür. Also sie sie bleiben bei monetären Anreizen. Ich.
Wäre jetzt schon irgendwie mal überzeugt ich würde schon glauben, dass also sie haben lange genug drüber nachgedacht, dass sie jetzt wahrscheinlich,
spontan schon alle Ads Edges berücksichtigt haben. Ähm das Einzige, was ich also das Einzige, was wir darin begrüßen können, ist, wenn Sie sich damit durchsetzen,
Wird eben dieser Energieverbrauch auf jeden Fall sinken? Aber ich will natürlich auch andererseits gespannt, ähm ob sie's hinkriegen,
weil sie müssen ja dafür diesen diesen Merch machen und andere davon überzeugen,
dass man dieses Staking machen möchte, ne. Also ähm IFA muss ja,
Die Mehrheit der Leute überzeugen. Bitcoin hat ja auch äh also,
abgesehen davon. Ich glaube, das hatte ich hier auch schon öfter erzählt und auch übrigens in dem Vortrag, den ich immer noch empfehle, soll den Shoutouts verlinkt. Ähm dass IFA ja auch durchaus schon mal ein Fork gemacht hat, indem sie eine,
ähm eine Transaktion, die jetzt ihnen irgendwie gerade nicht in den Kram passte,
obsolet gemacht haben, also rückgängig gemacht haben. Sie haben sich also quasi an ihr Primärversprechen gebrochen und seitdem gibt es ähm Ethereum Classic und was weiß ich, Ethereum oder was auch immer.
Ja, so heißt das.
Ne? Das könnte das das kann denen jetzt auch passieren. Das ähm dass die Leute sagen, nee hör mal äh ich habe hier so viel Geld für die scheiß Hardware ausgegeben und.
Irgendwie habe ich festgestellt, seitdem es diesen IFA-Merch gibt, sind sind Grafikkarten auf eBay echt gar nicht mehr so viel wert, wie ich dachte.
Die unsichtbare Hand des Marktes will irgendwie gerade keine Grafikkarten haben und ähm äh hat jetzt ihr äh ihren äh ihre Hand um meinen Hals, ja.
Bin mal gespannt, ob das passieren wird, aber auf jeden Fall können wir dieses sollten wir dieses Phänomen hier mal.
Ankündigen. Eva heute 3 Prozent hoch. Ich sage nur.
Ja es ist ja es ist natürlich ein interessantes Experiment. Es ist insofern ein interessantes Experiment, weil es halt auf der einen Seite verspricht ähm,
absolut untragbare Eigenschaft dieses Systems äh abzuschaffen, was durchaus ja zu begrüßen wäre, ja und damit sozusagen.
Ja, ja, eine, zumindest die, die jetzt, sagen wir mal, äh,
unmittelbar auf die Umwelt gerichtet ist als Problem, ja? Und nur,
letztlich bleibt natürlich auch, wenn dieser Umstieg funktioniert, was überhaupt nicht,
garantiert es, ja, weil du hast ja gerade gesagt, Sie haben an die Edge cases gedacht,
Da ist es so in der Eigenschaft von Edge cases, deswegen heißen die auch so ja, dass man die schnell so übersieht und das ist sozusagen.
So Fälle sind, wo man eben potenziell vielleicht nicht vorher richtig äh dran gedacht hat oder zumindest nicht ausreichend
drüber nachgedacht hat und es dann sehr wohl passieren kann, dass einem das dann äh aus den Händen genommen wird auf einmal, dass der
Unsicherheiten, Ungerechtigkeiten, Leaks kleine Probleme et cetera passieren. Das ist ja auch schon öfter passiert und man darf halt auch nicht vergessen, dass das dieser
libatäre Feuchttraum ja dieser dieser sich selbst vermehrenden Kryptogelder halt nach wie vor äh gefährlicher Unsinn ist, weil das ganze Geld kommt halt einfach nur durch Leute, die da rein investieren.
Weil einfach dieses ganze System nichts produziert und keinen inhärenten Wert darstellt, ganz im Gegenteil.
Unter anderem eben durch dieses Proof of Work, aber eben auch durch den sonstigen Aufwand, der getrieben werden muss, vor allem auch erstmal Geld vernichtet,
Das muss ja alles immer irgendwo herkommen und deswegen versuchen sie sich ja die ganze Zeit diesen ganzen Quatsch einfallen zu lassen mit ja aber hier ist eine tolle Anwendung.
Unterstützen jetzt Künstler und dann kommt dieser ganze NFT Unfug,
Wenn man jetzt mal einfach nochmal auf diesen NFT-Markt schaut jetzt nach einem Jahr halb, was davon übrig geblieben. Alles, was jetzt groß.
Eine ganze Menge Kohle in den Taschen von den Leuten, die vorher IFA hatten und jetzt Geld.
Ja, aber die Leute, die da angelegt haben, die stehen halt da mit irgendwie leeren Versprechen und mit leeren Taschen, weil die da jetzt ihre.
Die wollten ja auch einen NFT haben. Die haben ja ein NFT.
Ja die haben jetzt den NFT auch bekommen und jetzt merken sie irgendwie, dass sie äh nix anderes sind als irgendwie ein Witz in der Wolke
Diese ganze äh Idee von, dass das irgendwas wert wäre und dass das irgendjemand nur später nochmal haben wollen würde, einfach von Anfang an äh Unfug
war und auch bleiben wird. Das heißt, da ist viel Geld verbrannt. Im laufenden Meter äh wird überall
permanent beschissen und geklaut, also wenn man mal einfach mal ein paar Blocks äh verfolgt, die sich mit diesem Thema auseinandersetzen. Es ist einfach täglich,
täglich werden da einfach Millionen betrogen und beschissen. Und zwar vollkommen egal welche äh Währung das ist und vollkommen egal ob das Proof oder Proof Steak oder,
Die das diese ganze.
Der ganze Tempel, der da aufgebaut wird mit mit so Sachen, mit ja aber guck mal hier haben wir uns was einfallen lassen,
wo wir das alles zum Einsatz bringen können,
dreht einfach dieses Prinzip von von von Bedarf und Lösung einfach permanent um. Ja, da wird irgendwie ein komplett neues Web ausgerufen. Ja
drei. Ja, was kann denn das Tolles? Ja genau das Gleiche wie das Alte auch
Aha, aber warum? Ja, aber ist toller, weil jetzt läuft es auf unserem Scheiß. Ah super, okay, gut, dann heißt ihr, ihr äh
zeichnet hier eine eine Welt, die total bedrohlich ist, weil irgendwie Google, Apple, Amazon und so weiter und die, denen gehört alles
aber ihr der einzige Vorschlag, den ihr macht ist, ja hier haben wir etwas, das läuft langsamer, versteht keiner, die die Technik außer äh ihr selber wenn überhaupt.
Am Ende gehören das dann alles diesen Kryptobuden, wo irgendwie wahrscheinlich eine sehr überschaubare Zahl von Leuten dahintersteckt weltweit, die einfach mit diesem ganzen Kohle macht,
und die die ganze Zeit äh sich albern benehmen und auf irgendwelchen Kryptokonferenzen Dinge von sich geben, die einfach,
Jugendfrei sind. Also das ist dieser diese ganze Welt bleibt einfach scary und schlimm,
Und da wird halt auch irgendwie ein Prof auf Steak äh nichts dran ändern. Nichtsdestotrotz ist das jetzt ein interessantes.
Nicht mehr den Planeten kaputt. Das muss man Tim, man muss auch mal einen Punkt geben.
Mehr Moment, wenn wenn das so kommt. Äh ja, es ist jetzt ein Versprechen,
Versprechen ist es ja so eine Sache in dieser Szene. Also äh gucken wir mal und selbst wenn es so ist hast du immer noch Bitcoin,
Immer noch irgendwie den Großteil dieses Marktes ausmacht und was auch nicht im Ansatz so angelegt ist, dass das irgendwann mal auf so einem Proof of Steak äh,
wechseln könnte und dieses Problem wird ohnehin bestehen bleiben. Und jetzt zu sagen so, na ja, aber meine Bitfolger heißt aber anders und kann zwei, drei Sachen anders, ändert nix an der Tatsache, dass du immer noch in diesem selben,
Denkraum bist und dieser Denkraum ist an sich das Problem, weil er einfach so eine
staatsfeindliche Grundideologie fördert ja die einfach so Thesen in den Raum setzt und sagt so ja äh
Zinsen sind äh an sich ein Problem und hier hat Geld sei an sich ein Problem und äh es wird
die ganze Zeit zu Zeuge Jehovas mäßig eigentlich so der Weltuntergang prophezeit. Und sie haben jetzt hier irgendwie den Wachturm und den kannst du kaufen.
Den Wachturm kaufst und durchliest, dann dann wirst du dann auch gerettet, wenn die Apokalypse kommt. Das das ist ja im Prinzip das das selbe Prinzip.
Die sind auch genauso charmant und und und interessant diese Leute äh wie diese Zeugen Jehovas, die anderen irgendwie permanent überall auflauern.
Also ich würde es trotzdem begrüßen, wenn die Zeugen Jehovas den Planeten nicht mehr kaputt.
Ja okay, gut.
Trotzdem bleibt es jetzt und deswegen haben wir das jetzt erwähnt. Es ist jetzt ein interessantes, informatisches Problem, was jetzt grade gelöst wird. Das war
Wurde viel geredet über Proof of Steak und es wird auch viel gezweifelt an Steak-Modellen, insbesondere ob dann die
anderen Versprechungen mit, ja, wir sind ja total dezentral und so weiter damit irgendwie eingehalten werden können, wobei viele auch bezweifeln, wie ich finde, zu Recht, ob das derzeit überhaupt schon der Fall ist, weil du hast so auch
innerhalb dieser ganzen Kryptowelt äh extreme Zentralisierungsbewegung, ja, du hast eine extreme Stärke dieser Exchanges und äh
äh Providern et cetera und natürlich auch von den Leuten, die den eigentlichen Code schreiben, der letzten Endes das alles implementiert, also der
tatsächlich beschreibt, was Bitcoin tut, was dieses Netzwerk tut und das ist halt kein
offener demokratischer Prozess, an dem ihr da teilnehmen kann, sondern das ist eine relativ überschaubare Gruppe von Leuten, die das so steuert.
Und äh von daher äh bleibt abzuwarten, inwiefern das äh alles so,
kreiert dieses Proof of Steak betrifft, ist es so, ein Infomat, also interessant ist aber nicht so wichtiges, informatisches technisches Problem und dann werden wir jetzt demnächst mal
wissen, ob sich Sinn so was tatsächlich auch durchsetzen ist, weil abgesehen von den technischen Dingen wird viel auch von den.
Sozialen Dynamiken abhängen, die sie daraus jetzt entstehen und das werden wir erst,
Na ja, in frühestens in ein paar Monaten, glaube ich.
Was ja jetzt dann schon machen, ist das also Eva war ja haben ja nicht den Fehler gemacht äh,
von anfangs nur auf ähm
eigene Wallets zu setzen und das der Community mehr oder weniger zu überlassen, Miningpools und so weiter aufzustellen, sondern die sagen ja jetzt schon hier, du kannst Solo-Home-Staking machen, es gibt Steaking, es ist Service, es gibt,
Pool-Staking und es gibt Centralis Exchanges und diese,
Ja, überall wo Geld im Spiel ist, gibt's halt eine Zentralisierungstendenz, es gibt äh Philosophen, die das äh Kapitalakkumulation genannt haben. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wer das war. Ähm,
doch weiß ich sehr genau ähm und ähm.
Bei da sind sie zumindest jetzt schon so, ja hier, da da gibt es äh bieten sie dir bieten sie diese Möglichkeiten halt wieder an, ne,
Aber ja, schauen wir's uns mal an. Immerhin, müssen wir's erwähnen, haben wir gemacht und äh da müssen wir durch mit den Themen.
Kommt nicht so gut raus hier. Doch, ich habe hier habe ich einen Hund der pinkelt.
Fliegt aber auch so ein bisschen. Ja, wir sind durch, Tim, oder?
Nehmen Sie drei Mal täglich Hundeurin und alle ihre Kryptoprobleme verschwinden im Weltall.
Cyberspace.
Ja, das waren auf jeden Fall die Nachrichten der heutigen Woche. Es wird alles äh besser. Wir kriegen Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Dann denkt endlich jemand an die Kinder und bei bei IFA denkt jetzt endlich jemand an.
Ja
Und Kaninchen sind gar keine Rudeltiere.
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Graben Füchse eigentlich Löcher?
Ich glaube ja.
Als so verwirrend.
Haben die nicht boy, also haben die nicht einen Fuchsbau? Fuchsbau. Ich glaube Fuchsegrablöcher. Graben.
Löcher. Graben gehört zum Verhalten der Füchse.
Siehst du mal, gesicherte.
Wo sie.
Praktische Informationen von Logbuch Netzpolitik. Damit könnt ihr jetzt damit könnt ihr jetzt einschlafen.
Das Internet ist so geil. Fuchsratgeber Punkt CH hat einen Artikel mit dem äh warum Kraben Füchselöcher in meinen Garten. Ja.
Bitcoin vergraben hast.
Wo sich Umgebung und Boden dafür eignen, liegen sie baue mit Gangsystemen an, in denen sie ihre Jungen aufziehen.
Im Garten graben sie Röhren an den unmöglichsten Orten. Ja, es sind Fuchsbauer. Graben gehört zum Verhalten der Füchse.
Welche Löcher? Sechs ist super. Ist es haltbar, sagt welche Löcher graben Füchse?
Das ist die entscheidende Frage Tim. Wie Tim gräbt der Fuchs, weil wir müssen das Internet ja vor dem verstecken. Sie können sehr tief graben.
Wenn du wenn du Hühner hast äh musst du 80 Zentimeter tief den Zaun in den Boden vergraben.
Unglaublich. Linus. Der Tag ist doch like.
Ich froh, dass ich keinen Garten habe. Ey, Witze deines Lebens nicht mehr froh. Fuchs, Igel, wer da.
Ganz schön was los. Ich sage dir, leg dir einen Hase zu, der grillt wenigstens keine Löcher.
Wo wir da sind.
Tschüss Leute, bis nächste Woche. Tschau.
Ich bin ein Rudelhasen.